it's a new week and that means new
releases and this week we get a creepy
horror game coming to PC with a twist
it's called the flock you're brought
into this dark cruel world is one of the
flock a clawed light-footed monster with
the goal of obtaining the light artifact
which turns you into the carrier you can
only win as the carrier but the rest of
the flock want that artifact and that
means they're coming to kill you the
light will burn their skin but only if
you catch them moving turning this into
one of the creepiest versions of red
light green light you've ever seen it's
common in games of this style for you to
die but the flock is releasing with a
limited number of player lives once
they're gone they're gone no more
players no more game so get in when you
can and play until you're extinct become
one of the flock on the 21st also coming
up this week is the fourth chapter and
the critically acclaimed tales from the
borderlands series reese and Fiona are
forced by queenpin Valerie to travel to
Helios and retrieve the next quartz
upgrade but that's all the info you're
gonna get the story continues on console
on the 18th and on mobile on the 20th
we've all been curious to what Mike
Biffle the guy who made Thomas was alone
was gonna make next and people were
happy to learn its stealth based game
called volume which is coming out this
week on pc ps4 and Vita volume story is
based on a modern take of Robin Hood
you'll also be happy to know that Danny
Wallace the original narrator from
Thomas was alone makes a return to
volume as the voice of AI you'll get
super stealthy Metal Gear style and
manipulate the various guard types to
get your treasures and leave unscathed
your heist begins on the 18th
going to quickly go through a few ports
that you might want to know about
remember zombie that was originally
released on Wii U of course you do well
actually it got some decent reviews and
it's coming out on pc ps4 and xbox one
the 18th if you've ever wanted to try it
the ps4 exclusive velocity 2x is no
longer exclusive this week coming out on
pc and xbox and i recommend it resident
evil revelations 2 makes its way to Vita
on the 18th final fantasy type-0 HD is
coming to PC on the eighteenth and smite
gets out of beta and officially releases
on the Xbox one finally trying three
pops out of early access and into a
brand new 3d world with artifacts of
power as with the other trying games you
take on the role of one of three heroes
zoya the thief Pontius the night and
Amadeus the box makin wizard solving
puzzles and fighting giant monsters you
can do it solo or online or with local
co-op I'm always crying for more local
co-op games so thank you frozen bite you
can pick up this beautiful game on PC on
the 20th for further details visit
gamespot com release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week
Oh